[Musik]
ja besondere anlässe besondere bild
lagezentren heute wollen wir uns noch
mal genau ansehen wie es denn zu diesem
angriff auf den supermarkt in krems
schock auf dieses einkaufszentrum am
store einkaufszentrum durchgekommen ist
was russland behauptet und warum diese
russischen behauptungen ja relativ
einfach als lüge entlarvt werden können
die bilder kennen wir dieser markt wurde
dort angegriffen wir haben gestern abend
das video gesehen von präsident
zwanziger was er veröffentlicht hat das
eben direkt den angriff auf diesem markt
zeigt hier wir können es uns nochmal
ansehen hier die mega explosion hinter
diesem kleinen parkplatz das ist der am
star markt den wir dort sehen und wir
sehen eben wie diese riesige rakete vom
typ k h 22
können wir sehen ob das jedoch direkt
rein kriegen wie die auf dem markt zu
fliegt und dann auch hier oben sehen wir
sie und daneben auch dort explodiert
diese rakete man muss sich das mal
vorstellen das ist eine 1964 in betrieb
genommene rakete die bereits in den
späten 50er jahren
entwickelt wurde die s 11 meter lang ist
5 tonnen schwer allein der geschlechts
kopf wiegt hier etwa eine tonne und die
wurde entwickelt um westliche
flugzeugträger mit einem einzigen schuss
zu zerstören das war also die idee gegen
flugzeugträger und große kriegsschiffe
sie einzusetzen heute benutzt die putin
um damit städte anzugreifen
was sagt aber russland wie das ganze
entstanden ist also warum gab es dort
die toten oder warum gab es überhaupt
ein feuer an diesen supermarkt und wir
sehen uns das einfach mal an was
russland hier behauptet dass hier sind
ist die nachricht vom russischen
verteidigungsministerium die von der
russischen botschaft im vereinigten
königreich
geteilt wurde wichtig einmal hier die
karte wir haben die russische
behauptungen es gab zwei angriffe zum
einen auf eine munitionskiste auf einen
maschinen werk hier oben zu anderen auf
einen bahnhof und in der mitte hier
sehen wir dort ist der supermarkt soll
angeblich supermarkt sozusagen
dazwischen getroffen worden sein oder
eben mit in mitleidenschaft gezogen
worden sein russland behauptet ich
übersetze das mal dass ein
hochpräzisions angriffe am 27 juni
stattgefunden hat der auf waffen und
munition der usa und der europäischen
länder in krementschouk gerichtet war
der präzisions angriff angriff habe die
westlichen waffen zerstört und dabei sei
es hier steht es zu einer explosion zu
einem feuer gekommen dieses feuer habe
dann einen leerstehenden supermarkt in
mitleidenschaft gezogen und wir wissen
mittlerweile dass es eben dass es eben
völlig falsch ist dass das einfach
nichts passiert ist weil wir haben zum
eingesehen dass eben wirklich die rakete
direkt den supermarkt trifft das auf den
meter genau veröffentlichen oder
verortet ist es aber auch mal an es gibt
nicht nur diese aufnahmen sondern es
gibt auch andere aufnahmen aus einem
nahe gelegenen park und dort sieht man
noch mal die mega explosionen die
erfolgen und das interessante ist eben
wir sehen also hier die
überwachungskameras insgesamt fünf
perspektiven sehen dass es zwei
unterschiedliche angriffe nämlich gab
nämlich einen angriff
bereits früher auf das einkaufszentrum
wir sehen hier zwei läufer die
feststellen dass hier hinten die
menschen wecken dass wir hinten etwas
nicht stimmt die menschen haben gesehen
irgendetwas ist passiert und wir sehen
gleich mal wir gucken jetzt hin die
gucken etwas ist da passiert was ist da
los und kurz darauf eine zweite
explosion eine heftige explosion die
direkt neben stattfindet und wir wissen
mittlerweile dass dieser erste angriff
dem einkaufszentrum gegolten hat bis
zumindest als einkaufszentrum getroffen
hat und der zweite angriff dann diese
diese fabrik dort die maschinenfabrik in
der angeblich westliche waffen gelagert
sind dafür gibt es keine beweise
getroffen hat auch hier nochmal das
ganze
machen dass eine weitere perspektive
hier gab es den ersten angriff der mann
ihr trägt sein kind weg versucht also zu
flüchten und wir haben jetzt gleich den
zweiten angriff der hier passiert und
auch wenn wir das noch mal genau ansehen
dann sehen wir von wo der angriff
erfolgt ist nämlich
wir haben hier einmal rauch der
aufsteigt das ist der erste angriff
gewesen das ist wiederum das am store
einkaufszentrum das bereits angegriffen
wurde der mann rennt also hier mit
seinem kind weg und wir wären gleich
sehen hier viel näher in dieser
maschinenfabrik gibt es dann dienen die
zweite attacke also eben uns das noch
mal bis zu ändern wie gesagt der mann
flüchtet da oben sehen wir den rauch den
aufsteig der aufsteigt von dem
einkaufszentrum einen 500 meter weit
entfernt und jetzt eine mächtige zweite
explosion erst diese explosion trifft
also hier die fabrik das heißt wenn dort
irgendetwas explodiert ist dann ist das
erst minuten später gewesen und wir
sehen hier keine zweite explosion oder
sekundär explosion ähnlicher ähnlicher
art wir sind also nicht etwa nato waffen
oder ähnliches was explodiert das
sondern andersherum zuerst wurde der
supermarkt getroffen durch die erste
explosion
und in einer zweiten explosion wurde
dann dieses maschinen werk getroffen ob
es dort überhaupt irgendwelche waffen
gab das ist völlig unklar
[Musik]